- You have questions?
I sometimes have answers.
Bear's ready. I'm ready. Are you ready?
Robin, Discord, "Why do
people twitch in the middle
of their sleep and scare
the peewoop outta me?"
You go through different stages of sleep,
and when you're in your
deepest stage of sleep,
you actually turn off your
musculoskeletal movements.
That neurological system shuts down
but sometimes when you're
going in between stages,
it doesn't fully shut down
and you're still in sleep
and you're dreaming so
some of those movements,
actually do get through.
Bear once did that too and kick me.
I was upset with him.
"What actually causes the
sensation of an itch?"
Well, this is a complex process
that's primarily histamine driven.
There is a specific type
of nerve cell fiber known
as the C fiber.
These are the receptors
that actually initiate
the sensation of an itch.
Usually, a response to a
mechanical or chemical process.
It's an inflammatory response.
It's a form of an inflammatory response.
Discord, Naomi multifandom,
"Why are vaccines usually
administered in the shoulder?"
Well, it's a great deltoid muscle.
A lot of circulation.
It's quick. It's easy.
You don't have to get
really fully undressed
in order to make that injection happen.
Back in the day we used
to use the gluteus maximus
or the buttock.
Now, it's a little bit invasive
and it's easier to just go
in the shoulder and do the same thing.
YouTube, The House Office,
"Why are you a fluffy
cinnamon roll I must protect?"
First of all, I ain't
no cinnamon roll, okay?
The reason I aint no cinnamon roll
is because while I am delicious,
I am healthy.
Like a doctor?
- [Sam] I even sensed it's coming--
- But you don't know what
direction they're coming from.
- [Sam] There is no preparing--
- You don't know what
the word is gonna be.
- [Sam] You can't get ready
for something like that.
- "What can cause a constant
ringing in someone's ears
other than loud music noise,
what can get rid of it?"
This is really interesting
because tinnitus
is a constant ringing in the
ears and it can be a ringing,
could be a buzzing,
it's all sorts of sounds that can happen.
And a lot of times, the
reason why my patients come in
is as a result of cerumen
impaction or ear wax blockages.
Another thing that causes it
is sensorineural hearing loss.
You actually develop hearing loss
for one of many different reasons
and as a result of losing actual hearing,
you start hearing ringing in your ears,
which is manufactured by the actual nerve
that transmits the sound.
A lot of people think it means
you're hearing something.
It actually could be a
form of hearing loss.
That's why it's very important
to always get it checked out.
Discord, Arielle, "A lot
of medical shows, movies,
you'll see med students
shocked at being exposed
to cadavers for the first time.
Does this ever happen in real life,
where seeing a dead
person for the first time,
a med student will get sick or faint?"
Yeah, it happens.
Also, the fumes of the
formaldehyde are pretty stenchy,
if that's a word.
I was kind of in awe the
first time that I saw them,
but the scary part was when I was studying
for an exam late Friday night,
that was for an exam on Monday,
being alone in a cadaver lab,
in the dark,
(thunder rumbling)
hearing noises, thunderstorm
outside, no-brainer.
Discord, Jess Michiyo,
"I always get a runny nose
because of spicy food.
What is that about?"
That is about capsaicin.
It is a nutrient that
is found in spicy foods
that actually bind to specific
receptors in your body,
giving you the sensation of burning.
There's no actual burning happening.
It's tricking your body
to think it's on fire
and as a result, your body protects itself
by trying to lubricate the area,
releasing mucus, et cetera.
It's a great way to clear
your sinuses, by the way.
"I'm considering buying
a posture corrector,
do they really work?"
Generally speaking here, I would say, no.
I want you, when you come
in with a poor posture
is to figure out A, what's causing it,
and B, to actually allow
your body to fix it.
Or if it's bad enough posture
for an anatomical concern,
refer you to an orthopaedic
specialist to figure out
why that's happening.
Posture correctors almost end
up doing more harm than good
in many cases, where they
weaken your core muscles,
your stability muscles, and as a result,
making you more likely to get injured.
There are certain ones on the
market for specific conditions
that may work but I would
generally try and stay away
unless your doctor
absolutely recommends them.
Discord, Kristen g, what up Discord?
For those of you who don't know,
we have a private Discord where we chat.
Patreon members only, sign up down below.
"What's the best way to
get electrolytes after
a hard workout without adding sugar?"
Electrolytes are not added through sugar.
Electrolytes are essentially salts
that your body needs to function.
And the way that you get these
is by eating foods or beverages
that contain those electrolytes.
Sodium doesn't taste great after a workout
but after a grueling one,
it really does help you absorb the water
and stay more hydrated.
Back in the day they
used to use pickle juice.
Sure, tastes good too.
Not bad, I like it.
I like pickles (mumbles).
"Is there a way for a civilian
to test and see what kind
of nutrients their body
has a lot or a little of?
I'm always confused about what to eat
and it would be great to
know if I'm eating too much
or too little of something."
Currently, there's no
such thing on the market.
Yes, we can do specific blood
tests to see if you're low
on certain vitamins or if you're anemic
and things like that.
But generally we don't
screen for these things,
if you feel great and
you have no symptoms,
there's no point looking for them.
'Cause a lot of times, if you feel good
and your lab values a little bit off,
we still decide not to the treat the value
because the reality is
we treat the patient,
not the lab values.
"Why do our stomachs growl?"
Usually 'cause they're angry.
No, I'm kidding.
The reason they growl is
because of peristalsis.
The muscles in the stomach,
actually try and churn the food
in order to be...
Act as a form of mechanical digestion.
'Cause remember, there's
multiple types of digestion,
there's chemical, mechanical,
mechanical being chewing,
peristalsis, the stomach churning,
and that makes a growling noise.
Also, remember when
you're dealing with fluids
and there's bacteria inside our gut,
there's also gases released.
That gas, as it makes its way
through the digestive system,
can make those noises
and then at the end of the day, we fart.
Lance McPhee, YouTube,
"How often should you
shower and wash your hair?"
I have this argument so often
because there are people
who say you have to shower
every single day and
should washed your hair
every single day.
And that is in fact not reality.
The decision to wash your hair
should really be individualized
one, a holistic one.
Meaning that yes, if
your hair is very greasy,
or your scalp is itchy, or
there's a lot of dandruff,
maybe a good reason to wash your hair.
Yes, if you come home and you're smelly
from the gym, please shower.
But otherwise, like if
you just had a normal day,
it's not absolutely
mandatory that you shower,
and it's not absolutely
mandatory that you need
to use shampoo.
And depending on your hair type,
also decides how often you
should be washing your hair.
Those with very fine hair, maybe
every day, every other day.
Those with more textured
hair can go several days
without washing their hair
but know that the more
often you wash your hair,
the more that you actually take off
some of those important
oils off of your scalp,
you can actually cause
damage, more irritation,
dry out your hair, et cetera, et cetera.
When it comes to showering, same thing,
your skin doesn't like hot water,
your skin doesn't like having
soap all over it all the time.
In fact, your shower should
be really, ideally short,
like three to four
minutes, just focusing on
like you're growing your armpits.
That's about it.
"Why do so many people set a
step goal count of 10K a day?
Is there any scientific reason for this?"
(shouts loudly)
The 10K thing doesn't really mean much.
Look, whatever way you
choose to get active,
it will be healthy for you.
If you're increasing from 5K
steps to 7K steps, amazing.
If you've been working out one day a week
and you've gone to three
days a week, amazing.
I will never be that
rigid doctor that's like,
(sighs deeply)
"I see by your watch here,
you've averaged 9999.9 steps.
Disappointed, it's time for
me to cut you as a patient."
"Is eating burned food bad for you?"
Actually it is, NekoMouser,
you actually create all these
cancer causing chemicals
when you eat burned foods, so
ideally you wanna stay away
from charred as much as possible.
In fact, marinating
your meats help prevent
some of those hydrocarbons
and other toxic nutrients from forming.
Not a nutrients, chemicals from forming.
Actually, eating greens with
your meats helps decrease
some of the cancer
causing minerals as well.
Keep calling them different things,
nutrients, minerals, they're chemicals.
Chewy time.
"Does banging one's head
from the side actually shake
water out from your ears
or is that something they do in cartoons?"
Don't bang your head.
That's how concussions happen. Just jump
and the gravity will do the trick.
(laughs loudly)
"If someone gets stabbed in the stomach,
will the stomach acid
seep out into their body
and start dissolving their organs?"
Yeah, it's very problematic when someone
has a stomach injury.
It won't completely dissolve their organs
but it'll cause damage,
it'll cause a peritonitis.
Hyper Shadow Sniper 76,
"When you're performing
chest compressions,
you break the ribs, right?
Couldn't that broken rip
puncture an organ below
because you're putting
so much pressure on it?"
You can, but guess what?
If you're performing chest compressions,
that person's already dead
and you're trying to
bring them back to life.
So anything you can do
to continue their time,
by circulating the blood that's already
in the circulatory system
that has some oxygen left,
you're buying them some
extra added survival type.
It's why you don't do chest
compressions on people
who are alive.
Tahra, Discord, "Is there a
way to suppress my gag reflex?
I literally gag every
time I brush my teeth."
I had a patient tell me
the exact same thing.
What I told them, this
is kind of a weird trick.
Put his thumb, tuck his
thumb underneath his fist
when he's brushing his
teeth and for some reason,
this worked very well for him.
Easy enough to try
but if it's happening quite often,
seeing your doctor and figuring
it out if everything's okay
in your oral cavity is
probably a smart move.
Sam Bowers from three feet away,
"You've said there's a much
higher fiber content eating
a fruit itself as opposed
to just drinking the juice.
Do I also lose a lot of
fiber in homemade smoothie
because the fruit is getting
broken down by a blender,
or does the blender not
break it down enough
to alter the fiber volume?"
Good question, you, Sam.
And the answer is yes.
The beginning of that mechanical
digestion by your smoothie,
actually does decrease
some of that fiber content
because your body has to do less work now.
- [Sam] Thanks, Dr. Mike!
- I watched "The Office" medical scenes
and reacted to them right here.
I bet you didn't know that
they did chest compressions
on "The Office," CPR, CPR.
(bouncy music)